it took simple a while to find himself
sometimes i'm writing it for us with my
bad english and people don't understand
this so i just want the [ __ ] peace
in the world that's all i want
but after the uncertainty and
disappointment of his earlier years on
navi it was simple's time to show the
world what he was truly capable of just
perfecto and simple he needs a
multi-kill first found twist aggressing
they have to double peak he's getting
his shot he's hitting another one simple
oh simple that's unbelievable what in
his name number one in the game he's
done it again 2020 looked like it was
going to be the year simple finally won
his long-deserved major the year he
would indisputably prove who was the
true goat of counter-strike with this
roster you have brighter future okay i
mean we don't know what's gonna happen
but still
this roster with this individual skill
we can beat any team but it wasn't meant
to be there was no major in 2020 as the
world was engulfed in a global pandemic
and the few esports events that did
happen took place online from the
outside looking in it seemed as if
simple's one chance had passed him by
like he was cursed to never win the big
trophy but simple wasn't ready to give
up would you really quit cs to play well
around
listen
if i was astralis that won four majors i
would probably think about this you know
besides i have
this year has been simple's best year
yet going into pgl stockholm he had it
all the drive the talent and the team
but the real question was would he
finally have his major oh simple with
the off got the first one more close-up
oh of course he has that as well and at
a third that is spectacular he's at the
major and he's not wasting any time 1v1
on simple he's got it simple just hop on
the bomb and stick that defuse crimson
easy
we're gonna find the noscope dexter
[Music]
that's the face of a man who's wondering
who doubted he's the best player
[Music]
fans have argued about whether or not
alexander's simple castiliam is csgo's
greatest player for years it has long
been one of the game's most prominent
conversation starters for anyone ever in
the history of counter-strike that wants
to try and challenge simple for the for
the best player of all time i can't even
imagine the kind of work they'd have to
put in what an outrageous player simple
on an individually skilled level is
obviously like by far the best but at
some point when you have a conversation
on the greatest player i think you do
need to include you know the team
accolades in there it might seem weird
to people who come from other esports
that our goat in in cs go is you know
a guy who's never won
the major especially when the other
players will tend to throw around have
and that's kind of what makes simple
simple the fact you have this guy who
like achieved the status of the
so-called you know god king of cs go
without ever actually winning the major
during his time on hellraisers flip side
tactics team liquid and of course navi
the ukrainian phenom has been a shining
example of what it means to have a truly
infinite skill ceiling right now we need
to take a look at a very very pivotal
very crucial moment right here in the
timeline of the event simple with an
offline record today scoring his fourth
ace in a single event that is a record
and he keeps on delivering the only
thing missing that would make simple's
goat status official was a major there's
a lot of players that
couldn't win major before you know
it's maybe too early i always think that
if i didn't win some then i need to work
on myself and to find more my mistakes
maybe it's not inside game maybe it's
outside or maybe it's my communication
or maybe when i'm tilted sometimes you
know so i'm always trying to fix myself
people have floated many possible
reasons for why the trophy eluded simple
despite his beastly stats and incredible
in-game performances despite the fact
that simple knows he's the best and
everyone knows he's the best and he can
safely call himself the best
there's still that one knock against him
there's still that one knock against
them that there are lesser players on
lineups from years ago that won a major
that have that one up on you know the
god emperor of cs go right
back in the day the consensus was that
it was probably his attitude that was
the issue what are you doing you [ __ ]
idiots let's go together and win or i
gonna leave simple was passionate about
cs go and sometimes that passion flared
so hot it burned the people around him
including a few of his teammates when he
first moved here i mean i knew what to
expect i knew
him and adren wouldn't get along very
well i knew
you know it would probably be like a
ticking time bomb and you know only a
matter of time until it exploded where
you know simple made it either him or
adren
and you know obviously as we can see now
it's that was what it was with team
liquid simple was in the running for a
major win twice mlg columbus and esl one
cologne unfortunately both events were a
disappointment for the team and for
simple himself i feel like it's first
chance to be with steam and quality for
one million dollar major
and then we start losing because maybe
of me because i didn't hit my shots i
feel so sad plagued with homesickness
and feeling increasingly frustrated with
the direction his career was taking
simple decided to return to ukraine and
take up the black and yellow on notta
sincere
i want to win every tournament in the
world i want to help create new era of
nato spencer
since joining navi in 2016 simple has
teamed with some of the greatest names
in the game igl extraordinaire zeus op
legend guardian and 1.6 veteran edward
he formed powerful in-game duos with
navi's other long time mainstays
electronic and flamey simple also had a
chance to play with a few untested
players energetic igl boomage the
enigmatic perfecto and most recently
navi junior up-and-comer bit all of whom
proved that more experience didn't
automatically trump the need to prove
oneself but even so it seemed like the
stars never lined up right for simple
and his major to finally come together
and never was this more apparent than in
2020 when a pandemic effectively
cancelled esports simple had endured
years of haters and doubters stiff
competition from young players like the
french prodigy xaiwu not to mention the
excruciating back pain from carrying
some of navi's more ineffectual rosters
year after year everyone's laughing
everyone's smiling having a great time
simple
and just when it looked like at long
last simple was poised to win csgo's
biggest prize there wasn't even a major
for him to play in he just put on a
clinic in katowice they win that
tournament it's huge it's supposed to be
the start of the navi era they ask him
on stage like is this the start of the
navier he says yes the casters think
like this is going to be it we are going
to be living in navi dominated
counter-strike and then
coveted
online era navi took a bit of time to
find their footing but not having lands
certainly didn't stop simple from being
amazing yeah this is like one of
simplest favorite teams to play against
i think he loves the chaos i think oh
don't knife him don't do it simple oh my
god vinnie is gone navi one away from
the two-and-oh victory one kill away and
of course it's simple to deliver it one
hell of a game
we're gonna find the noscope onto dexter
the no scope headshot now in a one
passes one can he get this one simple
with the two no scope clutch next over
the headshot nico to follow and this is
looking so crisp right now they had the
call that molotov from nexa is
everything they needed simple though
know what he's turned around he's got
three kills in the space of a second and
now it's a one-on-one he's gonna go for
the bomb plant he's inside of the smoke
and ammonic he's got the pistol out he
knows
but simples escaped out through the
smoke not dead yet comes back for a
little bit more this can't happen he's
on the bomb he's going for the full
defuse ice cold from evidence oh no
he takes him down anyway the undertaker
even though most of the tournaments that
year as well as a chunk of 2021 were
held online navi managed to slowly but
surely collect even more silverware to
add to their trophy cabinet simple both
posted up fires off a warning shot and
simple as well does one better and
they're just walking in oh my goodness
i'm more for the ace
a record breaker from simply takes all
five that was the fight they were
waiting for electronic flash off the
door for the repeat simples got more
massacre with the ak spray lovely to
observe but now as it's the 1v1 on
simple it's kind of simple just hop on
the bomb and stick that defuse crimson
lands the no scope and still wins the
round simple does it with flair they've
been given a lot of room now
navi completed the intel grand slam in
756 days the third team to ever do so
and collect the million dollar prize
that went along with the title and while
a year and a half might seem like a long
time considering the state of the world
for a big chunk of it navi's
accomplishment was nothing to scoff at
hi haters i'm here again it's easy
cameras lights everything yeah just uh
there's no your place haters
i'm just kidding by all accounts simple
was having an absolutely insane year and
fast approaching was the only remaining
hurdle on his way to officially becoming
the uncontested king of cs go the pgl
stockholm major they had everything they
won the slam they had the best rifler
the best offer the best for like they
had the best igl the best coach like
that everything everything was gelling
this was it and if they don't win this
one you enter no excuses territory where
it's just like what the hell do you need
to win a major now and i do think that
that was a conversation going into
stockholm the pressure was definitely on
for simple in a way that i don't think
it was ever on before
heading into pgl navi qualified directly
for the new legends stage since their
regional major rankings put them in
first place in the cis alongside online
era superstars gambit esports at this
point simple had 16 mvp medals and
multiple in-game records to his name had
attended seven different majors with
three different teams and been on the
losing end of two major grand finals
after the year navi had if they couldn't
win in stockholm it didn't seem like it
would happen at all and simple felt the
weight of the world on his shoulders i
heard it from a lot of guys that navi
should win and i just
tried to imagine
how we losing you know
and it was so terrible that i wanted to
win more you know but this is simple the
god of cs go that we're talking about it
turned out he wouldn't have to worry
about losing at all and that's why
they're here that's why they win
good shot from simple a follow-up shot
through the corner
of the doorway
this is brutal yeah it's now got the
angle axles never going to expect this
bit with the second shot connects and
simple in the meantime finds another
headshot
oh and then another one
where does this guy do it shiro now the
last one alive here for gambit hoping to
be the hero oh my god that is disgusting
yeah that's the face of a man who's
wondering who doubted he's the best
player in the world
holding on at the moment to the bombsite
finds an awkward timing but perfecto is
spot-on
and simple has yet to be put into play
and it's all over
16-3
after plowing through every opponent and
dispatching one of their most
anticipated matchups gambit in what
could only be called a veritable stomp
na'vi were about to face g2 esports in
the grand finals and as fate would have
it g2's lineup had a long deprived major
contender of their own bosnian cs go
legend nicola nico kovac nico and simple
who'd been friends for a long time
wished each other the best but at the
end of the day only one of them could be
a major winner only one could reign
supreme and since neither wanted to jinx
their chances they both played it cool
it's the major in the end like
it's the most important event
of the
the whole cs time you know we never had
bigger prize pool we didn't hammer for
two years the pressure is there but we
are just here to fight you can always
lose you know
so when you lose this confidence or
you start to think that
they're better you you start losing so
you're just trying to upgrade our game
from game to game and just trying to
learn our opponents a grand final win at
pgl stockholm could mark another
important accomplishment for na'vi so
far their major run had been flawless
the team had yet to drop a single map
and they intended to keep it that way
during the first round of the finals on
ancient
to be seen
the bomb now planted uncontested i say
uncontested
a brief chance and through the smoke
simple
the grand final he's the one pulling g2
through but a 1v2 the bomb is ticking
and that's the end of that 16 to 11.
g2's pick goes the way of an rv nation
but g2 were not about to be just another
sacrifice on navi's altar they were
ready to fight back although that would
be no easy task playing on nuke a map
navi hadn't lost on since may so it came
as a bit of a shock when simple and his
squad found themselves facing a 14-7
scoreboard in favor of g2 a gargantuan
swing
in the momentum of this series
and the g2 fans raising the roof they
know just how close you two are to
pushing us all the way g2 were a measly
two rounds away from taking map point
and forcing a third deciding game and
wiping out navi's pristine map win
streak with their backs against the wall
navi needed a miracle and of course
simple was going to provide it
oh bit catches next just before he can
tuck in and jax is not long for this
world either
0-100 right there right it's way too
quiet it's way too quiet g2 had no
information perfecto has a smoke to play
around already repels the invaders bit
comes in but nico does too
does it really happen and two headshots
you'd need a whole lot more simple
catches him after we play on it was
simple on that ewp
times
[Applause]
open he's got the bomb in his hands he
has to plan simple finds him and we go
all the time
show that clip to your mother that says
it's just a video game
but miracle comeback or not g2 weren't
messing around they were not going to
give nuke or the major up without a
fight almanac posted up aggressively
he wasn't spotted but jax might have to
react he pushes in dimples waiting it's
up to hunter and he's delivered when it
matters simple was low bomb was spotted
electronic partners up with him back
turned and hunter continues to defend
his honor three frags
30 seconds nico looking to activate
takes to all three
he wants to go again
and so does electronic without surely it
g2 return the favor and we go over time
number two looks aware walks into the
line of side barrel spotted ammonic
misses and that's going to be it simple
removes the awp
and we're keeping things level again
they're coming in this is fast from navi
bursting into the site and already the
bodies are dropping g2 needs something
simple denies
and 20 is found
g2 disintegrate how much left did g2
have you know at this point what's left
in the tank is there any gas remaining
simple can almost feel it
10 seconds by the plan oh no that's
falling apart that's gonna be nico
there's no time he just has to watch
that clock tick down this is it
[Applause]
i'm taking the major
and just like that simple finally had
his major
the god was finally granted his godhood
the doubters the haters the naysayers
anyone who's ever said he wasn't the
best to ever touch cs go
was now silenced
stockholm stand up and celebrate because
you're champions
of the ptl major stockholm 2021
the king had his crown and the goat was
finally undisputed
it feels like i told myself that i will
stay in navi
and we'll measure with them i promised
myself
and we did it and
a lot of people didn't believe and make
some jokes but we [ __ ] did it and
major is ours major is navi
[Applause]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit us up on our twitter
instagram facebook and tech talk
[Music]